as a Laker an alltime Laker one of the
greatest of all time how did you feel
about them hanging the inseason
tournament Banner it was a loophole
there would you like to hear the
loophole I would love to hear the
loophole what colors are the banners
they are all yellow and purple and this
one is black and gold it's not really a
banner it's just a flag what I call an
accolate flag there's that clip of Kobe
going around where he says we don't hang
division banners we only hang
championships I don't but hold on it is
a championship it is a championship but
the loophole is so like I said it's a a
accolate flag and you're okay with it if
they would have had a yellow I'd have
been upset because it's black and gold
it's an accolate flag so I don't mind